ALAN VIVERETTE: Hi.
I'm Alan Viverette, a software
engineer on the Android UI Tool
Kit team.
In today's DevBytes,
we're going to cover
how you can add closed
captions to your video using
the new closed captioning
APIs in Android 4.4 KitKat.
These APIs allow you
to attach subtitles
to your video that are
displayed according
to the user's preferences.
Let's start with
a quick overview
of what's new for
captions in Android 4.4.
First, users can now
specify systemwide
captioning preferences, ranging
from whether captions should
be shown to what color
they should be shown in.
For most developers
though, you won't
need to worry about
reading these preferences
or rendering your own captions.
Simply adding a subtitle
source to a video view
is enough to show
captions according
to the user's preferences.
In this DevByte, we'll
cover how you can quickly
add captions to your
existing video views
and make it easy for users
to toggle the settings that
control how these
captions are rendered.
First off, you may want to add
a menu to your application that
lets users quickly modify
caption display preferences.
Here's a sample implementation
for onOptionsItemSelected
that opens the system
caption settings activity,
which you can also reach
by opening the Settings app
and navigating to Accessibility,
and then Captions.
There you can toggle
captions on and off
and change rendering
properties like font size,
background color,
and text color.
Here's what that
looks like on device.
It shows a preview
of what captions
will look like in
your apps video view.
You can change things like
caption background color
and select a custom style that
changes things like font size,
language, et cetera.
Now, let's take a
look at how to attach
those captions to a video view.
Android natively
supports loading
WEBVTT formatted captions.
You can find more
information online
about this format and how to
convert between various caption
formats.
Here's a basic example
of what WEBVTT time text
data looks like.
It lets the framework know
when and where to render text
over the video.
To attach these subtitles
to a video view,
we just need to add
a few lines of code.
Here we're opening
an input stream
for locally stored captions
in both English and French.
However, you could
just as easily
attach an input stream created
from a network resource.
But that's outside the
scope of this DevByte.
If the user has enabled
captions in Settings,
they'll see them
when the video plays.
Here's what that looks
like in a very simple app.
The captions are rendered
in the user's chosen style,
white on black, using
the correct positions
from the time text file.
Now we've covered the
most basic use case
for adding captions
to a VideoView.
However, this might not
cover all use cases.
If VideoView doesn't
fit your needs,
and you find yourself
implementing custom caption
rendering, you can still
respect the user's captioning
preferences by
loading information
from the Caption
Manager Service.
You can read more about
this class, including
usage examples, at
developer.android.com.
Thank you.